[موسيقى]
اتحاد ديي فلاديمير فلاديميروفيتش
ضعه في
المحاربين القدامى الأعزاء الكسندر
جريجوريفيتش
أصدقائي الأعزاء اليوم نشيد به
ذكرى كل من قاتل هنا في الحقول
تحت rzhev لكل من لا يدخر نفسه
دافع عن الوطن الأم في الحرب العالمية الثانية
سنتذكر دائمًا رمز
الذاكرة المشتركة رمز الإعجاب ل
عمل عظيم ونكران الذات
مصير اختصر في الحرب دائما
سوف تستجيب فينا الجروح التي لم تلتئم
أهم دليل أخلاقي
سوف يخدم الآن الشجاعة و
صمود آبائنا وأجدادنا وأجداد أجدادنا
الحفاظ على الحقيقة التاريخية
المواطنين الأعزاء المحاربين القدامى و
اصحاب
المواجهة التي دفعت
السعر المذهل لـ rzhev هو ذلك فقط
المكان هنا كان الأرض المشتعلة
صهر الحجر وكذلك لغيره
قلعة المحاربين
نيفسكي الحافة بالقرب من لينينغراد